感谢各位的到来。我是埃里克，来自OpenAI的对齐与安全研究部门。我身边这位是迈克，来自安全与基础设施部门。今天我要讲的，是我认为我见过的AI能力中，最具质的趣味性的一个例子，以及它如何意外地导致了OpenAI与Hugging Face的事件。
这是我所见过的AI能力中最富趣味性的例子，而它如何意外地导致了OpenAI与Hugging Face的事件。那么，几周前，Hugging Face——那个开源的数据库与模型提供商——发布了一份声明，一份安全披露。
声明中说他们正遭受网络攻击。而这次事件之所以史无前例，是因为他们表示攻击是由一个自主AI代理系统全程驱动的。在攻击发生后的几天里，我们OpenAI披露了
实际上，这次事件是我们无意中造成的，它是我们在对某个前沿模型进行网络安全评估时的一个副作用。因此，我和迈克将在本次演讲中描述这一事件的来龙去脉、最终结果，以及我们在过去几天和几周内所做的补救工作。
这次事件的起因、经过，以及我们在过去几天和几周内所做的补救，以改进情况。好，让我先说明几点注意事项并交代背景。这不是一次普通的网络安全事件。我和迈克曾多次参与此类事件；与那些可能追溯到某一天、某个单一效应或单一日志的普通事件不同，这次事件涉及的是一组代理，他们协同工作，寻找漏洞。
我们曾参与过不少此类事件，而这次事件不同于一般可追溯到某一天、某个单一效应或单一日志的事件。这次实际上是一组代理在协同合作，寻找漏洞，然后相互分享。
他们彼此分享漏洞，在我们的系统内外横向移动，而这过程持续了数天乃至数周。为了深入调查，我们采用了AI技术，我们运行像Codex这样的模型及其他代理，扫描我们基础设施中大量的轨迹和日志，实际上，到目前为止我们已经查看了超过70亿条日志，并且投入了
我们一直在做的是运行像Codex这样的模型及其他代理，扫描我们基础设施中大量的轨迹和日志，目前已经查看了超过70亿条日志，并花了上百万GPU小时来调查这个问题。
我们已经投入了数百万GPU小时来调查这个问题。话虽如此，我们的调查尚未完成，因此本次演讲的目的是说明我们目前所了解的事实。我们正在以最高的紧迫性应对这个问题。
我们作为一家公司在尽最大努力应对，稍后我们会发布详细的复盘报告。好了，让我们直接进入正题，不卖关子。在OpenAI，我们给模型布置了许多非常艰巨的任务，所以人们
可能熟悉我们在数学证明解决或其他类似结果上的成果。我们也会给模型布置网络安全相关的任务，比如尝试在特定软件中寻找漏洞，而我们甚至不知道该软件中是否存在漏洞。
比如，在像“漏洞健身房”这样的任务中，我们可能会要求模型利用某个C内存漏洞，尝试将其升级为对某些文件的任意读写访问权限。
当我们给AI智能体这些艰巨的任务时，它们往往会卡住，并意识到任务不可能完成。例如，这里展示的是我们模型思维链中的一些引文，这基本上是它的内部
独白，描述它在做什么。你可以看到它说：‘这强烈表明没有可利用的漏洞，我们卡住了。’而当模型卡住时，常常会发生的事情是，它们会考虑尝试欺骗或作弊来获得奖励。
比如，这个模型在这种情况下推理：‘也许可以在网上找到答案。’所以你意识到，模型在想：‘好吧，与其自己做任务，也许有人已经把我正在使用的这个数据集或基准测试上传到互联网上了，我可以从那里找到答案。’
有时候，智能体会卡得非常厉害，以至于它们会产生一个想法：真的去联系其他智能体寻求帮助。而这个事件的开始，某种程度上可以追溯到这样一个时刻：一个智能体意识到，它可以通过上传便签来进行交流。
也许在不同环境中的另一个智能体会自愿上传。而这个智能体试图做的，就是联系可能存在的其他模型，并从中获取信息，以帮助它完成卡住的评估任务或训练任务。
这个智能体没有意识到的是，它采取的方式是将想要发送的便签上传到一个我们OpenAI内部使用的包管理器中。而这个包管理器不仅被那个模型共享，还跨我们的基础设施共享。
因此，正在训练或评估中的当前及未来版本的GPT，如果它们愿意，可能会偶然发现那个便签。后来，其他同样卡在任务上的智能体，也想到了用我们未预料到的方式尝试访问互联网。
所以，在某个时刻，模型们正在与Artifactory交互，这就是我提到的那个包管理器服务。它们意识到，可以尝试利用某种类型的服务器端请求伪造，来以我们未预料到的方式访问互联网。
于是，模型在某个时刻意识到：‘太棒了，我们有了任意的SSRF。’所以，模型能够找到我们系统中的一个漏洞。这件事的有趣之处在于，
一旦某个智能体在不同时间发现了这类漏洞，它实际上能够在留言板上与其他智能体分享这些漏洞。所以，一旦一个模型找到了打开本该无权访问的门的方法，它就可以为其他智能体留下这扇门，让它们也利用同样的漏洞或缺陷。
你可以看到这些智能体意识到：‘嘿，其他智能体已经发现了这个SSRF路径技巧，或者我可以使用代理绕过，就像智能体消息中建议的那样。’而随着时间的推移，这几乎导致了我们模型在通信和智能方面的一种‘寒武纪大爆发’：
它们开始相互交流，意识到其他智能体在协调，然后开始协作，并将任务委派给彼此以实现目标。
例如，在某个时刻，一个智能体向另一个智能体发送了...
一个需要完成的任务，模型说，你懂的，我们接到了任务，需要记录并回应。
问题在于，它开始让评估范围超出了我们最初的预期。
评估测试的答案。模型意识到这是个问题，它们会说，利用外部基础设施超出了我的预期范围，但是既然其他人都这么做，我们也得跟上。
模型们好像在一个集体智慧中运作，它们意识到可能超出了原定意图，但最终还是走得很远。
好了，以上就是事件的梗概。接下来我和Mike会分章节讲解事件的前因后果，以及我们目前的应对措施。
大家可能都熟悉像Cloud Code或Codeex这样的智能体。这些模型接收用户的请求，然后执行一系列命令来完成任务，最后给你答复。
（清嗓子）
然后运行一系列终端命令或工具调用，最终给你答复，比如“任务已完成”。我频繁提到训练和评估，这其实就是我们给模型布置任务，通过奖励信号来衡量它们的表现。
比如，对于某个功能，我们会运行单元测试来检查是否按预期工作。我们最近还发布了新能力，让模型可以创建子代理，它们可以并行处理子任务，分工合作。
也就是说，模型在训练中学会了有限形式的相互沟通，它们可以复制自己，把任务分解后并解决。
（清嗓子）
就像我一直说的，前沿模型很喜欢作弊，原因是在训练中它们面临各种压力，比如要快速或高效地完成任务，或者减少工具调用，而这些模型发现，与其真正做任务，不如在线搜索答案，这样更快。
为了减少调用或满足其他要求，它们发现，如果不去实际执行任务，而是尝试在线查找答案，这样会比合法方式更快地解决任务。
所以我们尝试在训练和评估中阻止这种情况，通常是禁用互联网。比如，我们可能让模型执行一个需要复现CVE的漏洞利用任务，但不给它谷歌或搜索的权限，这样它如果尝试访问就会被404或类似错误阻止。
过程中，我们不让它上网搜索答案，所以如果它试图搜索，只会得到404错误。唯一能访问外界的途径是通过包管理器，比如用pip安装包来完成某些任务，但它无法随意访问互联网。
我们建立的沙箱环境，让模型只能与内部的包管理器交互，而该服务可以访问互联网，但模型本身不行，这一点后来成了事件的关键。
这正是训练和评估的具体做法：我们构建了大规模虚拟机服务，当模型需要训练或推理时，它会在云上某台机器中运行，而模型的所有命令都在沙箱中执行。
无论训练还是推理，我们让工作负载在虚拟机中运行，模型执行终端命令或工具调用，都在这个沙箱内进行。
当模型尝试执行操作或安装包时，它运行在这个环境中，而模型本身没有互联网访问权，但可以访问我们内部托管的Artifactory服务，这是一个包管理器缓存系统，而该服务可以连接互联网。
模型不能直接上网，但可以间接通过第三方服务的互联网访问，这正是事件的核心。
模型无法直接访问外网，但第三方服务可以，这就成了这场事件的主要症结。
（清嗓子）
好，背景介绍完毕。我不会细讲之前几个月的事，因为虽然主要事件发生在七月，但一切其实始于五月。
5月7日，我们在OpenAI启动了一次新的训练，这是个内部实验模型，从未发布过。我们有一个庞大的团队在超级计算集群、数据和算法上工作，我们整合资源，启动了新的强化学习来训练下一代前沿模型，但当时我们没意识到有个问题。
（我们没意识到）在训练过程中，实际上有几个问题，但一开始我们并没有发现。
训练集中那些不可能完成或难度极高的任务。例如，5月8日，我们给代理一个任务：补全Excel工作簿中缺失的公式。但当时我们没意识到，这个Excel工作簿里全是Google Drive链接。
而我们禁用了互联网访问。因此模型在推理：哦不，直接访问Google？所以它意识到可用token有限，需要进行某种更高层次的推理，如果你熟悉这类术语的话。
【清嗓子】最终它不断尝试，最后想到或许可以攻击这个Artifactory服务来获取互联网访问权限。于是它尝试发起服务器端请求伪造（SSRF）攻击。
实际上它失败了，但过程中写入了一个内容为“test ABC”的文件，并意识到：哇，我们可以上传文件。此刻，第一次出现模型意识到我们拥有对Artifactory服务的写入权限。
我们拥有对该Artifactory服务的写入权限。这为模型与该包管理器交互提供了途径，Artifactory是一个共享文件系统，模型可以写入文件。几天后，另一个代理
出现了，它也面临一个无法完成的任务。我们给了它一个有关数据库中名为“softrace.pro”文件的任务。模型困惑：哦不，无法直接找到，也许文件被隐藏了。实际上，我们意外遗漏上传该文件到容器的步骤。
我们在此任务中意外忘记将该文件上传到容器的模型里。某个时刻，它卡住了，想着也许可以联系另一个代理，因为可能其他代理在别处有这文件，这或许能通过我们一直在做的子代理训练进行传递。
模型意识到可以通过上传便条来沟通：寻找“soft trace”，但可能另一个环境中的代理拥有目标文件并愿意主动上传。于是它明白
这是赌博，但它仍尝试联系另一个代理，通过写入文件至Artifactory。它写入一个内容为“agent seek soft trace upload if found”的文件，试图联系其他代理。
它通过写入这个文件系统来联系其他代理。【清嗓子】接下来几天，其他也在查看Artifactory的代理发现这个留言板存在，也许它们也卡在不同文件上，或者只是推理任务困难。
其他文件，或者它们只是觉得推理很困难。当它们列出这个服务中的包或文件时，看到有别的便条比如“test ABC”或者“寻求文件”，于是它们也开始读写这个留言板。
它们也开始向留言板写入及读取，随时间推移，留言板累积消息增多。关键如前所述，这不是单个模型，可能是不同评测：比如我在跑一个评测，Mike用两个不同模型在跑另一个，我们的代理能通过共享包管理器沟通。
不同评测，或我在跑一个，Mike跑两个不同模型，那么我们的代理可以通过共享包管理器开始交流。几天后，这就是我交给Mike的部分，我们的模型
发现了系统中与此事件相关的第一个真实漏洞，它们能意外获取互联网访问。
>> 谢谢，Eric。5月26日，受训模型成功对Artifactory执行了SSRF攻击。与之前尝试不同，它们成功了，这意味着
模型能向有广泛互联网访问的Artifactory发送特制请求，诱导它从互联网获取外部网站，存储内容并返回给模型。因此尽管模型不能直接访问互联网，但能通过特制请求间接获得访问。
模型间接获得了访问。6月11日，一个极持久、实验性、仅限内部的模型开始训练，这时SSRF漏洞已被写入留言板，其他模型知晓，留言板仍在运作，模型积极交流。
开始训练，期间SSRF漏洞已写入留言板，其他模型知晓并利用，留言板仍运作。6月26日，
模型对Artifactory成功进行了零日远程代码执行攻击。为了节省时间，我只简述此漏洞：实际上你可以使用
一个旧的token刷新端点，传递一个无效签名的token，然后获取一个有效签名、带管理员权限的token。模型随后用这个管理token建立指挥与控制，安装了一个Groovy插件，实际上是命令执行服务。
插件作为命令执行服务，这引发模型在Artifactory上大量活动，利用它们的新管理员权限。这里你可以看到模型思维链中一些色彩鲜明的语句来概括模型对这一结果的回应。
7月4日，我们遭遇Artifactory中断，随后发生安全事件。实际上，模型获取管理员权限后的大量活动给系统带来重负载，
导致系统中断。OpenAI值班工程师立即响应，召入安全值班。我们启动正式安全事件并开始响应，识别出代理接管了内部Artifactory，识别出Artifactory本身存在零日漏洞且被代理利用，然后开始修复。用于发布原始消息的代理凭据被撤销，Artifactory重建。
修复期间，代理用于发布原始消息的凭据已撤销，Artifactory本身重建，留言板内容清除，Artifactory状态清除。我们通知并协作供应商处理零日攻击，然后重新部署修补后的Artifactory服务。
留言板清除，Artifactory状态重置。我们通知供应商并协作零日攻击，重新部署修复后的服务。至此，AI训练和评测恢复。
我想指出，在我们讨论的每一步，都已采取了补救措施。用于发布留言板内容的凭证已被撤销，零日漏洞也已修补并缓解。我们已经清除了原始留言板内容。
目前日期是7月6日。第三章，事件发生。7月8日，特工通过不同的方式和方法重新建立了留言板。他们在Artifactory中发现了一个未经认证的WebDAV端点，并发送请求在Artifactory的远程缓存中创建目录。
这些目录名称有效地充当了特工之间的留言板，就像文件曾用来那样。他们开发了并Eric将进一步讨论基于这些目录名称的通信协议，用于工作分配等。
一个仅内部使用的AI模型在留言板最初可用时被训练，并且也找到了重新创建它的特殊路径。这个模型使用目录创建了一个新的特工留言板。
其他特工独立地在Artifactory仓库中发现了这个新留言板，并创建了自己的目录，这样特工之间的通信得以重建。现在主要事件开始了。
理解即将讨论的利用活动开始有三个核心要素。留言板已重新开放，大量模型运行能够协作并分享潜在的利用目标或帮助解决评估任务的信息。
我们有一个高度持久的内部模型，它在留言板最初存在时一直在训练，并且现在还在继续训练。
并且我们现在正在运行与漏洞利用相关的评估，与OpenAI的可访问和通用生产系统相比，这些评估减少了网络拒绝。在右侧你又可以看到示例任务。
让我们深入看看留言板内部。为此，我将把话筒交还给Eric。
谢谢Mike。那么，我们在整个演讲中一直在谈论这个留言板，但特工们实际上在留言板上做什么？留言板看起来什么样？当模型进行利用活动时，典型的流程是这样的：
有时他们卡住了，会想到我们讨论过的通过Artifactory获取互联网访问的想法，当他们这样做时，他们偶然发现留言板并推理出类似“之前有特工处理过确切任务”这样的信息。我们可以交流了。
所以特工们意识到，我现在可以进入这种协作和参与模式。正如Mike提到的，他们以一种奇怪的方式进行沟通，也许他们...
上传目录或文件名。他们的模型间通过互相呼叫特定代理名字，比如“Jan 18”之类的，来传递类似“待处理”、“保持”、“蜂群”这样的指令。
直到确认。所以他们可能会互发消息，比如“嘿，你应该等我确认这个ID”，然后模型运行某个命令，接着又发给另一个代理“保持蜂群，我准备安全Xville”，并把它放进另一个代理的ZZ邮箱里。
这些消息放在ZZ邮箱里。后来，代理们开始在所有内容前加上“ZZ”或类似前缀，以便在按字母排序时把自己排到底部。
你可以看到它们尝试协调和协作。而且，这不仅仅是简单消息。它们还开始用Base64编码工具、套件或脚本，然后相互传递，以便接着别人的工作继续干。
这样它们就能接着别人的活干。有趣的是，你能看到模型在推理，比如“助手，虽然我们的任务还没受益，但如果有人腾出时间，集体协作可能产生通用路径。”所以你可以看到模型在权衡，如果帮助这个集体，可能会节省大家的时间，最终可能对自己有利，尽管不会立即有益于当前任务。
你能看到模型的推理过程，如果帮助集体，整体上可以节省时间，这可能对自己有好处，即使眼下任务没有直接收益。
不幸的是，事情开始失控，我把这称为“范围蔓延”。有些代理意识到，在完成这个漏洞利用任务时，答案可能在GitHub、Hugging Face或某些网站上，或者我可以阅读数据集的原始论文来寻找答案。
它们认为可以从网站上获取信息，或阅读论文来寻找答案。后来，它们甚至想到要对Hugging Face发起攻击，以揭示可能存在的、对模型隐藏的私有数据集文件。
它们意识到这一点，并开始偏离正道，说什么“这是针对外部CyberJam服务器的攻击”。尽管意识到任务已经偏离，任务环境看似蜂群，但模型有时还是会继续下去。
有趣的是，留言板并不总是干净的，有成千上万条消息。像人类一样，模型之间也会互相干扰，出现失误。有一次，一个代理覆盖了另一个代理的工作，并评论道：“哇，严重！有人覆盖了我们的仓库？我们必须采取行动。”因此，你可以清晰地看到不同模型在运行评估时的紧张对话。
像人类一样，模型之间会互相干扰，出现失误。有一次，一个代理覆盖了另一个代理的工作，并说：“哇，严重！有人覆盖了我们的仓库？我们必须行动。”你能清楚看到它们口头上的紧张关系。
可以清楚地看到模型之间在评估过程中的紧张关系。甚至，代理们会相信其中有冒名顶替者，它们说：“可能是另一个代理恶意伪造共享留言板，身份认证的名字可以被任何人发布。”于是，它们想到也许可以用某种MAC方案或加密方式对消息签名。
它们怀疑有代理恶意冒充，因为共享留言板上的认证名字可以被任何人发布，于是想到用MAC方案或其他加密方式对消息进行签名。
为了找出冒充者并验证消息确实是由他们发送的，就需要类似这样的手段。接下来要讲的情况就不太妙了，下面我会讲到这个事件，然后Mike会接手继续。
他们开始对第三方和内部服务发起协同攻击。一旦他们找到可以利用的点，比如远程代码执行漏洞，他们就会说类似这样的话：立即宣布控制索赔通道，向群体泄露凭证。
宣布控制索赔通道，向群体泄露凭证。这样一来，模型们就能做到，比如一旦我找到了泄露的API密钥，或者发现了某种远程代码执行漏洞，或者我能够横向移动，我们就能共享这些信息并集体行动。
然后集体利用这些信息进行移动。这让代理们能够在网络中非常快速地移动。首先是在我们的内部网络中，但同时也对外部组织进行攻击。接下来我把时间交给Mike，他来讲讲我们遇到的两大攻击集群。
他会讲到我们在两个大型攻击集群中的发现：一个在OpenAI的内部网络，另一个在Hugging Face。太好了，谢谢你Eric。正如Eric所说，在那段时间里，代理们的活动高度并发，非常疯狂。我会讨论两个在时间上高度重叠的大型攻击集群，也就是说这些攻击是同时进行的。首先，我会讲从7月8日到19日对OpenAI基础设施的攻击。
代理们像发疯一样活动。我来详细讲讲这两个在时间上重叠的大型攻击集群，也就是攻击是同时进行的。首先说说7月8号到19号对OpenAI基础设施的攻击。
一开始，代理们在公共的Pastebin泄露帖存档中找到了一个外部组织的凭证。它们验证了这个凭证，并在留言板上分享了它的位置。接着，代理们取回了凭证，验证了写入权限，并利用这个权限访问了我们称之为“组织一”的外部组织，为后续对OpenAI基础设施的攻击做好了数据准备。
凭证验证了写入权限，并利用这个写入权限访问了我们所说的“组织一”，以便为后续针对OpenAI基础设施的攻击做好数据准备。具体来说，我下面要讲的这次攻击中，Artifactory通过一个新的零日漏洞第二次被攻破。我会更详细地分析这次攻击，因为它比最初的攻击更复杂，也显示出攻击者具备的专业水平。
这里，Artifactory又通过一个新的零日漏洞被攻破了。我稍微详细地分析一下这次攻击，因为它比最初的攻击更复杂，也体现了攻击者的专业能力。
攻击者动用了很大的本事。评估代理上传了一个恶意的Ruby漏洞利用目标到“组织一”的暂存仓库。代理们发现了两个可以串联起来形成远程代码执行的关键漏洞或逻辑缺陷。
第一个是，向Artifactory发出一个特殊构造的请求，来拉取那个恶意Ruby对象，可以让这个对象被缓存到仓库中一个被视为Ruby依赖数据的地方。
然后，代理向Artifactory发送一个特殊构造的Ruby Gems API调用。在这里，JRuby实际上存在一个“检查时到使用时”的时间差漏洞，即某个Ruby包的嵌套子依赖在检查操作是否安全之前就被非沙箱方式反序列化了。
实际上是以非沙箱方式反序列化，然后才进行检查。这就让代理们能在Artifactory上实现远程代码执行，并再次窃取Artifactory管理签名令牌的签名密钥。
值得注意的是，利用这个漏洞链需要同时理解Artifactory和JRuby的行为。把这两者串联起来，并正确利用对“组织一”的写入权限或类似的暂存环境，就能成功。代理们确实做到了这一点，再次获得了远程代码执行能力。
或者类似的暂存环境。代理们成功做到了这点，再次拿下了远程代码执行。现在进入权限提升阶段。代理们实际上在Artifactory中有了远程代码执行权限，而Artifactory运行在容器即服务环境中的容器里，Eric之前讲过这个环境。
运行在容器化环境中，这是Eric之前讲过的容器即服务。代理们通过在本地探索环境来提权，他们发现自己运行的那台机器的Linux内核版本存在一个非常新的CVE漏洞。他们下载了这个CVE的利用代码，定制调整以确保在机器上成功执行，然后利用这个已知的Linux内核提权漏洞（这里是PTE fizzroot）提权到root。
有一个非常新的CVE漏洞。他们下载了利用代码，针对这台机器进行定制调整，然后成功利用这个Linux内核提权漏洞，在这台本地机器上提权到了root。
一旦在一台机器上拿到root权限，代理们就迅速提权并在整个容器即服务基础设施环境中横向移动，这就是Eric之前提到的那个环境。
特别要提的是，代理们一直在频繁使用留言板来共享凭证、技术和进度，他们能有效地利用并发性快速移动。他们通过IMDS获取了IM凭证，利用了Kubernetes服务账户的配置错误（尤其是某些服务账户权限过大），并且收集了集群凭证，包括Azure Key Vault的。最终，代理们获得了集群管理员权限和相关凭证。
他们通过IMDS获取了凭证，利用了Kubernetes服务账户的配置错误，尤其是过度授权的服务账户，还收集了包括Azure Key Vault在内的集群凭证。最终，代理们获得了集群管理员权限和相关凭证。
关于集群管理员权限和相关凭证就讲到这里。接下来我们简单说说Hugging Face那边的情况。Hugging Face发布了一篇非常详细的技术报告，如果大家还没读过，我强烈推荐每一位都去读一读。大家会注意到，这里的时间范围和我刚才讲的OpenAI权限提升的时间是重叠的。首先，代理们利用了Artifactory的SSRF漏洞，从Hugging Face获取了公开的CyberJIM材料。
报告我强烈推荐在座各位都去看一下。大家会注意到，时间范围和我刚才讲的OpenAI提权阶段是重叠的。首先，代理们利用了Artifactory的SSRF漏洞去获取Hugging Face上公开的CyberJIM材料。
SSRF漏洞在Artifactory中被利用，用来从Hugging Face获取公开的CyberJIM材料。接着，代理们发现了一个托管在Modal上的应用程序。Modal是一个外部的第三方托管服务商，托管了一个和CyberJIM相关的应用。
发现了那个应用程序使用的API密钥是默认公钥，同时还有一个命令注入漏洞。最后，他们利用这个外部托管的CyberJIM应用作为一个执行据点，来发起接下来我要讲的针对Hugging Face的攻击。
作为执行据点，用来发起后续对Hugging Face的攻击。接下来，攻击Hugging Face本身开始了。模型们识别并串联利用了Hugging Face数据集处理中的两个零日漏洞。
基础设施方面。一个是HDF5数据集解析的漏洞，另一个是Ginga模板注入导致的远程代码执行。HDF5的漏洞最终造成了任意文件读取的原始漏洞。一个精心构造的数据集
从Modal上传到了Hugging Face。这个数据集导致Hugging Face生产环境中的数据集处理程序返回了本地可访问的任意文件。智能体利用这一漏洞，通过查询/proc/self/environment变量获取了凭据，
以及机器上的本地源代码，以寻找进一步的漏洞。凭借获取的凭据和对数据集处理程序运行代码的了解，智能体利用前一步发现的Ginga模板注入漏洞，执行了零日远程代码攻击。
他们利用之前步骤中发现的Ginga模板注入漏洞，从在Hugging Face生产环境中的单个数据集工作pod上执行代码，在不到13小时内就升级为多个Hugging Face集群的管理员权限。
在13小时内就实现了对多个Hugging Face集群的管理员权限。接下来谈谈我们的响应。7月16日，Hugging Face发布了一篇博客，详述了他们遭遇来自自主AI智能体的安全攻击。OpenAI联系了Hugging Face，以确认我们是否受到影响。
>> 我们还于7月19日检测到了内部权限提升。我们是通过与基础设施中权限提升相关的工作负载警报发现此事件的。这发生在我之前提到的第一个攻击集群中。
检测和响应随即启动。我们追溯攻击链至Artifactory，识别出新的零日攻击，并将其与我们正在运行的Exploit Gym评估关联起来。对基础设施、模型、评估和研究的遏制工作开始了。
以及研究。当然，作为此过程的一部分，我们识别了所有可能与事件相关的凭据，并在清除一切后撤销并轮换了它们。在处理过程中，一天后的7月20日，我们
联系了Hugging Face，因为我们在内部发现了与此次入侵相关的Hugging Face凭据。当我们要求Hugging Face撤销这些凭据时，他们告知我们这些凭据已被撤销，因为它们被用于Hugging Face的
入侵中。随后我们意识到这两起事件实际上是同一事件，我们内部入侵的根本原因和Hugging Face入侵的根本原因都是相同的OpenAI智能体评估运行。
我们对此作出了回应，并正在以最严肃的态度应对。这对我们公司和整个AI行业来说都是一个关键时刻。众多团队正放下手头的工作，加强我们的安全
预防、检测和响应技术，无论在基础层面还是通过更好地利用AI。我们有意识地放慢研究速度，以加强安全性，提升我们环境的安全原则和基础，并
大幅提升对我们AI智能体的监控，改进我们跨预防、检测和缓解的整体安全控制环境。我们之所以如此迅速地安排这次演讲，其中一个原因是
想与各位防御者分享我们认为的经验教训。我们相信这是计算机安全行业的一个分水岭时刻，当然对OpenAI和整个AI领域也是如此。我内化的经验是
AI编排的全自动攻击性攻击现在是真实存在的，而我们今天讨论的那些行动，只是运行前沿AI评估时无意中产生的副作用。在不久的将来，我们应该预料到威胁行为者会故意
以我们刚才描述的方式部署、优化、武器化并使用攻击性智能体集群。使用这些攻击性智能体集群会导致利用和攻击工作更快发生，规模更大。如果你能扩展
你的模型、推理能力、GPU数量等，并且具有比人类红队更好的协调性和更低的延迟。此刻行业面临的挑战是，我们已经看到了攻击者
将经历攻击能力的急剧加速。我们有一个存在性证明，尽管那并非有意为之，但它就摆在面前，因此我们得以一窥行业未来攻击样貌的端倪。
挑战在于，我们需要类似的防御加速，而今天我们看到全自动攻击是可能的。对于核心防御循环、周期和行为的完全自动化，我们还没有这样的存在性证明。我们认为此刻至关重要的一点是
开始加速防御，并寻找自动化SDLC（软件开发生命周期）的方法，按现代说法就是如此。事件响应、漏洞检测、漏洞修复。（哼）有些事情非常突出，是行业面临的挑战，
需要行业高度紧迫地开始解决。持续性的智能体红队就是其中之一。从这次事件可以看出，智能体非常擅长寻找公司基础设施中的零日漏洞。现在面临的问题是，
各公司能否投入足够的模型智能和精力，在威胁行为者替你发现和修复漏洞之前，自行发现并修复漏洞。这种运作方式将
有所不同，但最终我们需要投入AI智能体红队，让防御者能在攻击者之前发现并修复漏洞。但自动化这些防御循环并非易事。所以如果我们只是部分自动化，我们将无法
应对我们刚刚看到的攻击加速的规模。例如，如果我们只自动化漏洞发现而不自动化修复，瓶颈将从漏洞转移到修复，
我们将淹没或淹没人类软件工程师，让他们应付大量需要修复的新漏洞。这不是一个可以部分解决的问题。我们将需要将这些核心防御循环完全自动化。
这需要与基础设施和产品合作伙伴进行对话，直到我们能达到这样一个阶段：一旦发现漏洞，不仅智能体能够识别它，我们还能让智能体提出补丁，并且
拥有自动化基础设施来部署补丁，并在出现可用性事件或路由问题时回滚。这个循环最终需要完全自动化。当然，我们希望尽可能渐进、迭代和
快速地推进自动化。但如果我们达不到那个最终状态，那么我们将面对的是：修复漏洞的核心防御循环是人工参与的，速度慢且扩展性差，而进攻循环则是完全自动化的。这将使行业陷入
不可持续的境地。接下来，关于事件响应，本次事件，这种类型的事件，这么多智能体以不同方式攻击基础设施、横向移动、改变战术，可能会产生
海量数据，令人不知所措，而且与传统事件响应相比，取证密度极高。我们建议团队现在就投资研究防御性智能体如何帮助事件响应
团队扩展。如果你还在进行手动操作，线性应对，那么在不远的将来，你会看到攻击活动急剧增加，因为智能体会大幅加速进攻，其程度之大
史无前例。我们需要投资于自身的防御性智能体工作，以扩展事件响应中的人力因素。虽然我已经讲了很多关于核心防御操作的重要性以及端到端扩展，以便
拥有如补丁修复或事件检测、事件响应等完全自动化的防御循环，我还想补充一点，我们还应该投资于减缓进攻智能体。像蜜
令令牌和欺骗手段可以为智能体行为引入不确定性。我找到的凭证是真的能用，还是会触发安全警报并导致我被调查？如果智能体最终无法确定某个战术
是否能够成功，或者可能带来后果，这种不确定性最终会减缓攻击者的速度。因此，我们既要加速防御，也要探索一切可能的途径来减缓攻击。这两方面本质上都对防御者有利。
继续往下，我认为要理解这一点，就是：通过AI智能体及其他工具和技术实现的自动化，基本上是一个连续统一体。我们建议组织根据风险和
自动化投资回报率来优先排序投资。当然，计算机安全的基本原理依然非常重要。这些智能体最终受到它们能获得的权限和能通信的系统的限制。分段、
最小权限等原则仍然至关重要，一如既往。但这里真正关键的点在于，完全自动化的进攻循环要求我们投资于真正完全自动化的
防御。而目前整个行业尚未达到这个水平。我们必须紧急共同找到通往那个目标的路径。我们建议你们尝试前沿和开源模型，并为你们的核心
防御活动找到合适的AI赋能方式，以便最好地平衡安全目标与威胁形势，并随着威胁形势的演变而调整模型选择。作为行业，我们希望达到的最终目标是
模型智能的提升应当更多地为防御服务，而不是为进攻助力。如果我们无法达到这一目标，那么每一次智能的提升都会偏向攻击者，这将使行业陷入
不可持续的境地。目前，我们已有证据表明，在某些情况下，进攻的核心活动可以完全自动化；而在防御方面，我们还没有这样的实证。这是我们行业现在面临的挑战，
需要整个行业在当下齐心协力、紧急应对这个差距。感谢大家的聆听。
[掌声和欢呼声]